[Music]
together
and just listen to me that's all it is
very simple all right baby
can they walk that way no no the other
one this way yeah okay
okay
so are you refusing to leave I'm not
refusing okay
you're gonna follow me all right there's
no way we're gonna do it because when I
try not to ruin your day but you gotta
understand
let's go this way very simple
I need a large
for me
all right
[Applause]
that's fine come on guys
back up that way back up you will be
arrested if you go into my team right
now you get what I'm saying yeah all
right here okay stay right there don't
go in don't worry
walk that way
walk that way I'm not even two commands
to go that way we're gonna start in my
scene right now and I will arrest you
get out of here that way he doesn't
listen you need to go that way all right
[Music]
okay
legitimately like why are you doing this
to me you follow us to my vehicle I will
put you in the back of it let you know
right now
what do you think I've done
who are you protecting and serving no
one's protecting anybody right now but
the public right now you have to be a
disturbance all right
we're gonna pat you down
I mean I can tell you what's in my
pockets
well he's gonna get it anyways
hey I mean a legal search
the back of the vehicle we have to put
we have to check you make sure you have
any weapons or anything on you okay with
our safety very simple it's protocol you
guys have guns I don't have guns
I'm afraid of you listen don't worry
about it
I'm serious though
what's your name
nothing wait what is your name and badge
number
45389 Torres and you are it's officer
Vera you're gonna see it on the eighth
one
okay and can I ask why are you guys
doing this to me because you don't
listen you're calling disturbance
I was in a public park it's a public
parking so go and start closing I'm not
causing problems no what are you talking
about
like
you're good he doesn't listen to us a
natural reaction to being restrained
like this if you were to be loose and
understand
talk to me like a human being
I'm confused though I don't understand
how you're having a cooperated
yeah those are my pants I'm telling you
there's a zipper in the back
you might have to move my arms I don't
know that that's going to get through
there
okay
where they have the handcuffs to take
off this thing hey we're gonna put them
back on do not resist or anything
because I will I will redirect you to
the right please okay please introduce
myself shake your hand and treat you
like a human being listen you're fine no
no I just I'm saying this like face to
face there's no part of the thing is
there once we put the cuffs on you and
we move you you that's it you have to go
but it happens
we're just taking off this taking off
this bro
very simple
hold on
I'm just trying to take it off and I
think I can't get to your pants
I mean I I feel like you still need to
like if you take it off now I'll let you
put them back on just un like
legitimately no you're good no no no I
won't be able to do it
come on
we're good now
okay so again there's nothing in the
back
a lighter
and a little case with some rocks in it
this is my phone and my wallet okay
there's nothing in those little ones
so um officer Torres my name is Morgan
what's your name
what's your first name
there's some rocks in there I told you
that
yeah
and you officer Fiona what's your name
Morgan Brian nice to meet you
what do you work on man we'll tell you
the answer yep
you're a student through there I was a
student I just got my PhD
[Music]
only for this stuff bro
especially you have a lot of things
going on good for yourself
[Music]
so I want to be very clear I've not
consented to any of this search
in the back of the car we're obligated
to do it
all right for safety reasons so it's not
a problem okay what do I do
huh all right here sorry one second what
is it again what do I need to do for my
safety they're good you're with us well
there's nothing happening with us I mean
that didn't work for Tyree knuckles
what was it Tyree Nichols what happened
we just got brutally beaten by five
police officers today do you think
everybody's like that no I think that we
need to be aware that what do I do as a
civilian for my own safety
you're not being treated anyway at all
very good
um
I don't know
have a seat have a seat
can I have my stuff back I'm putting it
in a plastic bag
oh can I have it back down yeah we don't
have it here in the front it's not gonna
be with you listening you're gonna
resist if you're gonna resist sit down
we'll give you a command so sit down you
gotta listen you got sit down
are you feeling that's very simple
you're gonna you're hit my wife's over
there okay well I will tell her I'll
tell her what's going on very simple my
wife
one of the costumes
what issue one in the costumes
no but just listen to him just sit
inside there you go that's all you have
to do
uh
[Applause]
they're more like a chicken there
yeah we got one here so he's gonna
monitor them
[Music]
or no
I'll get it on now
go hook them up
yeah
all right
thank you
huh
uh yeah I'm gonna go
we're gonna let me go